the NHS is something we are all blessed
to have but it's no secret that it's
creaking at the seams if we wish for it
to continue radical new ways of thinking
and needed the answer can always be
simply more money sorry Greg
I was pleased then to see the new NHS 10
year plan unveiled this week which aside
from just money focuses on new digital
technologies tic mental health services
in schools tech commitment to reducing
waste tic and a major focus on
prevention / cure double tick if we wish
for our supposedly beloved NHS to be
ever present we must all start to look
inward and take better care of ourselves
if we can't even be bothered to help
ourselves then why should we expect the
state to like you Michele I am broadly
happy to see the government announced
some more long term thinking for the NHS
we all know we need it and I think it's
good to acknowledge that there are some
really positive things in there the
mental health crisis as you mentioned
improvements to ite lots of positive
things however we're starting the year
agreeing Fiorina Bianchi will be up
there wasn't it but we'll a few things
actually first of all if you ask
patients and people who work in the NHS
their greatest concern its staffing the
government hasn't announced what it will
spend on staffing yet we have no idea
and I feel that this is all you post
frenzy well I was going to then say
Braxley even without brexit that is a
concern but brexit is actually moving us
in the wrong direction of staffing is
concerned 12% of NHS workers are from
overseas their future is more uncertain
than it ever has been and that really
puts at risk other advances in treatment
in improvements to service and the other
thing I wanted to say is that I'm a bit
conflicted about your line on taking
responsibility I'm not conflicted about
taking responsibility we should all take
responsibility for our well being but
something that happened over the last
few weeks was that medical professionals
called for obesity to be reclassified as
a disease
not a lifestyle choice and the reason
they said that was because they
recognize that obesity an area without
heavily influenced by health
inequalities by genetic influences and
by social factors now I'm not saying we
don't take responsibility for our well
being and diet but I think that the idea
of recognizing that there are structural
reasons why we have a huge crisis of
obesity a quarter of adults
I don't believe a quarter of British
people are just greedy I think it's
something much deeper than that and it's
another reason why we need to fund the
NHS properly to deal with the projects
that we're facing Nick's gonna Rex just
learn the reason people have fat is
because they eat too much or they drink
too much lost quite a few pounds but I'm
a keen student of history Michelle I am
the NHS is you know celebrated its 70th
anniversary last year how many five year
reviews ten year reviews or radical
revolutions have there been in those
seventy years 14 I just suspect you've
got the answer so this is the 14th
either 10-year plan five-year plan or
radical review simply throwing more
money at something doesn't necessarily
make it better no no there needs to be
there needs to be more accountability so
while you're heralding much of it the
reality is this they take now 20 billion
pounds of our money our viewers money
and there's no there's no accountability
for it but where is it that we can hold
Hospital chief executives even health
secretary do you agree with me most of
it where is the accountability so that
you know you know that this won't
completely work nothing ever will people
need to be fired when they screw up with
this amount of money
so just to pick up on athis points about
social factors I think when we're
looking at preventable illnesses often
there's an emotional reason behind it
like you said a quarter of people in
this country aren't just greedy and I
think what we actually need to do you
think are based tears a disease yeah and
I think the way - I mean I think we need
to intervene earlier I think where we
see children perhaps becoming obese
that's where the school needs to
intervene we need to educate parents
there's lots of things that we can do
earlier to
make sure that we save money in the
future and I have a clip that I'd like
us to look at which is Joanne Keeling
and this is a woman who's a former
patient at the rubber room Institute for
obesity
it is only down to me but I don't think
anyone can succeed without support you
know I don't want people sympathy it's
just I wish people had more empathy
because they don't know mastering
they've not walked in my shoes Greg yeah
Michelle you're gonna I'm gonna surprise
you but saying I agree with most of what
you're saying thank you there's an
interesting quote from the professor of
health economics at York saying the
extra 250 billion funding it's a woman
called Maria Goddard 20.5 the extra
twenty point five billion of funding
finishes is actually not remarkable in
terms of historical trends it works out
at as a three point four percent
increase in real spending an average
annual increases in spending on the NHS
since it was founded have been around
three point seven percent so no point
three percent higher in other words the
money is only a fraction above the three
point three percent estimated to be
needed to keep the NHS at current
standards but what I liked about the
review is that and Knicks fight you know
is it it's just another reviewer then
nothing changes or are they actually
going to use the digital technology in
the world to actually change it I mean
I've said I've said before on this and
this program I'm going to your GP is no
different to when I was a kid you know
you made an appointment or you sat in
the waiting as you sat there you went in
you witness saw the GP they had maximum
about five ten minutes and that was it
the consultation with a GP I haven't yet
has anyone I know I've had three how is
it done it is because I've tried to get
into my local NHS GP surgery and I've
had a month waiting list and I haven't
been able to wait a month so on three
separate occasions I've had to pay a
private lately so I have a private app
based digital it has to be saying
technology work
yes has one of the most lamentable
records of bringing in new to their
attempt at bringing in a patient
database and patient date we went down
as the worst implementation in the whole
of you that is down to change that
sounds a poor project management prop
poor project governance there's been
many many disastrous IT implementations
and just because that's you shouldn't
try to avoid it that was that was trying
to that was trying to put that everybody
in the community onto one database which
was just too difficult but do you think
things would be slightly different under
man Matt Hancock either because of his
job before and his and his relationship
with the digital community perspective
because I agree with everything to say
about tech and the NHS can't afford to
keep messing up mmm its operate we need
to get into the digital era but you
can't have an NHS with a great IT system
and no staff and I just want to play you
a clip from the shadow health secretary
on this point we've got shortages of a
hundred thousand staff across the NHS
we're short of 40,000 nurses were short
of 10,000 doctors and there isn't any
proposals today from the government on
how they're going to recruit the staff
for the future what is the point in on
bailing this big plan for the NHS if we
can't have the basics yet as a nurse and
where is the government's response to
the fact and it's a fact that brexit is
currently putting the NHS in jeopardy
and all of us who depend on it so that
is our biggest concern i can't think you
can say it's putting the entire NHS in
jeopardy there are aspects of it but the
NHS kids train to be nurses
they're artists out of theater as well
to be fair to him let's see what he says
the focus needs to be on making sure
that we support people in the community
that we support people through for
instance through GPS and that we ask
people as well as giving them rights for
free care free at the point of use we
also ask them to take responsibility
to keep the pressure off the NHS and and
make sure that it's there for people who
really need it so yeah and I do agree
with you after that the whole staffing
thing has doesn't Philippines of its
nurses in Australia health professional
is a serious problem it's not one that
you've been doing anything about or any
other movement about the EU and we
really should we still Romania nurse
solution is not to suddenly starve the
NHS and stuff which is what's happening
right now
what's your answer training by quite a
significant amount but it's gonna take
some use